the economic situation in the united
states is dire and there's many people
who psychologically have packed it in
and they're preparing for a recession
but the recent bank earnings coming out
of q2 show us exactly how the consumer
is doing on the ground our friends over
at john street capital they broke down
these bank earnings and they have tons
and tons of insights into spending
savings and credit quality trends
if we start with jamie dimon and jp
morgan they say that quote consumers are
in good shape they're spending money
they have more income jobs are plentiful
they're spending 10 more than last year
almost 30 percent more than pre-covet
businesses you talk to them and they're
in good shape we've never seen business
credit be better ever like in our entire
lifetime and that's the current
environment
on top of that if you take the combined
debt and credit spend is up 15
year-over-year also we can see that the
average consumer is spending 35 percent
more year-over-year on gas and about six
percent more on recurring bills and
other non-discretionary categories at
the same time they have yet to observe a
pullback in discretionary spending
including in the lower income segments
with travel and dining growing 34
percent year over year with spending
growing faster than incomes median
deposit balances are down across
different income segments for the first
time since the pandemic started though
those same cash buffers still remain
elevated of course lots of people are
focused on credit and that's still
healthy and what we can see there is
that positive trends in loan growth
across the business with loans up seven
percent year over year and up two
percent quarter over quarter now that
brings us to where we go from here which
is quote the future environment which is
not that far off involves rates going up
maybe more than people think because of
inflation there's a range of potential
outcomes from a soft landing to a hard
landing driven by how much rates go up
the effect of quantitative tightening
etc
this terrible humanitarian crisis in
ukraine and the war and then the effect
of that on food and oil and gas and
we're simply pointing out those things
make the probabilities and possibilities
of these events different it's not going
to change how we run the company the
economy will be bigger in 10 years we're
going to run the company we're going to
serve more clients we're going to open
our branch we're going to invest in the
things and we'll manage through that so
i always remind myself the economy will
be a lot bigger in 10 years
next up if we go take a look at
citigroup earnings we can see that
they're quoting higher rates and
quantitative tightening will keep
volatility high that said while
sentiment has shifted little of the data
i see tells me that the u.s is on the
cusp of a recession
consumer spending remains well above
pre-covet levels with household savings
providing a cushion for future stress
the job market remains very tight you
can see how resilient the customer is in
the us through the elevated payment
rates and the low level of credit losses
they have shifted their spend far more
to travel and entertainment which is now
outpacing 2019 levels when we go when we
take a look at wells fargo we can see
there quote while we're monitoring risks
related to continued high inflation
increasing interest rates and the
slowing economy which will impact our
customers consumers and businesses they
have been resilient so far when looking
at simple averages across our entire
portfolio consumer deposit balances per
account increased from first quarter and
a year ago and they remain above
pre-pandemic level
overall our consumer deposit customers
health indicators including cash flow
payroll and overdraft trends are not
showing elevated risk concerns
however we're closely monitoring
activity by segment for signs of
potential stress for certain cohorts of
customers we have seen average balances
steadily declined to pre-pandemic levels
following the final stimulus payments
early last year and debit card spend has
also been declining for wells fargo
debit card spending is up three percent
with transactions flat credit card
spending is up 28
although consumer credit utilization
rates remain below pre-pandemic levels
and payment rates remain strong with low
delinquency rates if we go take a look
at morgan stanley gorman stated that if
he had to use one word to describe the
environment it would be complicated
we have the russian invasion of the
ukraine obviously a historic occasion we
have historically low rates with very
significant rate increases going around
the world
we've got the tail of covet we've got
the fears of inflation and actual
inflation we've got enormous political
change in the uk supply chain issues
china-u.s relations etc so yes it's very
complicated i think it's important to
say though it is not 2008 complicated
this is a different type of financial
stress in the system frankly the banking
sector is much stronger than it was
going into the last time we went through
a major reset in 07 and 08 while we
might head into some form of recession
and i like many others have tried to
handicap it
we frankly guessing at this stage but i
think it's unlikely to be a deep and
dramatic recession at least in the
united states then if we take a look at
bank of america they said our u.s
consumer clients remained resilient with
continued strong deposit balances and
spending levels loan growth continued
across our franchise and our markets
team helped clients navigate significant
volatility reflecting economic
uncertainty as we enter the second half
of 2022 we believe we are well
positioned to deliver for our
shareholders while continuing to invest
in our people our businesses and
communities we can look at the trends in
their loans and leases according to john
street capital deposits and overall
asset quality along with consumer and
commercial portfolios still continue to
look strong another quote states that
across our 35 million core checking
accounts the us consumer remains quite
resilient consumers continue to spend at
a healthy pace the overall average
deposit balance for most client cohorts
are higher than where they were in the
first quarter and they rose in june
month over month they remain at
multiples versus pre-pandemic levels
customer data shows bank of america
spend at highest quarter ever with 1.2
trillion of total spending which is up
12 percent year over year also the
highest debit spending quarter on record
in june of 2022 spending was plus 11
percent year over year and transactions
were up six percent year over year for
the first two weeks of july spending is
up ten percent and transactions are up
six percent we see shifts on what people
are spending on experiences travel and
fuel and less on retailing in stores in
the second quarter we saw higher gas
spend and continued recovery and travel
and restaurant spending average deposit
balances remain elevated what these
reports from the banks are showing is
that although there's plenty of fear
when it comes to a recession is that the
consumer is still spending money they're
looking for experiences they're looking
to travel and there's some sort of
hangover from the covid lockdowns
regardless of what the economic data
suggests in terms of gdp contraction in
q1 and potentially in q2 many consumers
on the investment side psychologically
have prepared for a recession they've
seen their asset prices fall off a cliff
and they're hurting they're reeling but
the average consumer the people who
actually spend money in the economy to
consume goods and services they're out
there they're still spending and they
don't see a recession on the horizon
regardless of what you think is going to
happen this is a weird situation we've
got 40-year high inflation we've got a
federal reserve that's hiking rates
after gdp contraction in the first
quarter we've got investors who are
preparing for a recession we've got
consumers who are spending like there's
only good times ahead i don't know where
we go from here but what i can tell you
is that there haven't been many times in
history where we've had this concoction
of different ingredients we're both
investors consumers economists and
people at the federal reserve and in the
treasury are all confused they're just
trying to figure it out make sure you
keep paying attention right now there's
a lot of moving parts and the future is
definitely uncertain what you always
should think about is how to prepare
yourself for the worst
but remember optimists win in the long
term so hope for the best
keep a good attitude and my guess is
that we'll get to the other side of this